>> So Matt, we've had a chance to look at your overall ancestry
by looking at your DNA on chromosomes one to 22 and the X.
>> hmm.
>> and that gives us a good overview.
But, specifically, we'd like to look at your
maternal ancestry, that is, going through your mother,
and her mother, and your mother's mother's mother.
>> hmm.
>> And we can do that by looking at a very specific subset of the SNVs.
>> Okay and, I think we're going to learn a little bit more about that
in lesson 11 of the course. But for right now can you tell us what's
the only chromosome that's passed from mother to all of her
children and through which we can actually trace our maternal lineage?